Herzlich willkommen im Tritolwerk.
Wir schauen uns jetzt an, was die ABC-Abwehrtruppe
des österreichischen Bundesheeres so drauf hat.
So, da ist ja schon mein Kommandant.
Herzlich willkommen bei der ABC-Abwehrtruppe.
Vielen Dank.
ABC hat jeder schon einmal gehört, aber wofür steht ABC eigentlich genau?
Das steht für automarer, biologischer und chemischer Abwehrbund.
Wir schützen die Soldaten  und vor allem auch die Zivilbevölkerung
vor automaren, biologischen Kampfstoffen als auch Gefahrstoffen.
Chemiekenntnisse allein reichen aber nicht.
Die Kernkompetenz der Waffengattung liegt in vier Bereichen.
Die ABC-Aufklärung, die Dekontamination,
das Retten und Bergen
und Brandschutz in kontaminierten Gelände und die Wasseraufbereitung.
Ihr seid so eine gute Truppe, dass ihr weltweit gefragt seid.
Die Austrian Forces Disaster Relief Unit ist eine Katastrophenhilfeeinheit die im speziellen
mit den Fähigkeiten der ABC-Abwehrtruppe weltweit zum Einsatz gelangen kann.
Habt ihr irgendwas für mich zu tun oder kann ich mir das ein bischen genauer anschauen?
Also ich kann dir nur sagen, die Frau Oberleutnant Niedermoser hat sich etwas einfallen lassen.
Wir haben heute einiges vorbereitet für dich.
Fein ich seh schon.
Über das ganze Aufgabenspektrum, schauen wir, wo du mitmachen kannst.
Ich muss ein bischen näher ran, das ist etwas leichtes für den Sommer oder?
Ja genau, das ist der Sommeranzug, unser Schutzanzug 90.
Und das ist unser Aufklärungstrupp, mit dem darfst du heute mitüben.
Und wir haben für dich auch einen Schutzanzug vorbereitet.
Ihr habt einen Schutzanzug für mich vorbereitet?
Es hat zirka 30 Grad, also gut, umziehen.
Du hast unseren Schutzanzug mittel an
und bist quasi bereit, dass du bei unserem Aufklärungstrupp mitmachen kannst.
Los geht's!
Das Labor ist gesichert,
jetzt gilt es noch Proben zu entnehmen, von den potenziellen Gefahrenstoffen,
die hier vorgefunden wurden und da werde ich helfen.
Soweit ich kann.
Der ABC Aufklärungsteil ist jetzt erledigt. Ok.
Und nach jeder Aufklärung folgt die Dekontamination.
Wir haben tatkräftige Unterstützung, sie
werden dir dann alles zeigen.
Ich stell mich mal an.
Ah, wieso bist du schon fertig?
Weil ich einfach schneller bin als du.
Alles Klar.
Schickes Gewand hast du an.
Damit wir das tauchen gegen ein richtiges Gewand, werden wir jetzt zum Rette- und Bergezug schauen,
und da gibt man uns eine Brandschutzbekleidung.
Ich darf dich jetzt an unseren Rette- und
Bergezugskommandanten übergeben,
den Stabsobermeister Fichtinger.
*Begrüßung*
Freut mich, dass du da bist, wir haben die ganze Nacht durchgearbeitet.
Handschuhe an, und dann gehen wir es an.
Gut, bereit.
Hallo?
Da ist die Rettung, wir helfen gleich.
So, dem Verwundeten geht's gut?
Ja.
Ja, es geht ihm gut.
Rettung erfolgreich durchgeführt.
Dank euch, ihr könnt es ja.
Gut Robert, jetzt hast du viel gesehen.
Und jetzt kommen wir noch durch den R&B Zug zu der Feuertaufe für dich.
Feuer im Sinn von...
Feuer. Feuer.
Die ABC-Abwehrtruppe des österreichischen Bundesheeres, wenn der Feind ein unsichtbarer ist,
dann ist sie nicht nur besonders furchteinflößend, sie ist auch sehr gefährlich.
Furcht, kennen die Frauen und Männer hinter mir überhaupt nicht.
Super ausgebildete Soldatinnen und Soldaten auf der einen Seite,
perfekt ausgebildete ABC-Abwehrkräfte auf der Anderen.
Und nicht nur bei uns in Österreich, sondern sie sind international im Einsatz,
rund um den Globus eine beeindruckende Gruppe.
Und ich glaube, weil sie gerade versammelt
sind,
ist jetzt eine gute Gelegenheit danke zu sagen.
Danke!
Bitte!